a school district in Glendale that's in
California not too far from here in Los
Angeles has hired a company to monitor
the social media posts made by a student
so this yeah that's right Jimmy this
company will be monitoring 13,000
students at 8:00 middle and high schools
we're talking about their Twitter
accounts their Facebook accounts
I guess snapchat and BK and if you read
if you continue on the story they're
only reading what's public so it's
what's out there it's what people are
tweeting and I mean you know the kids
that killed the Australian guy running
you know they now can go on that kids
Twitter account he's talking about guns
and their board and killing people and
so I mean you can gather a lot of
information about what people do that
doesn't bother me if kids are gonna go
out there and put [ __ ] out there on the
Internet and it's public and it's open
and a school can go maybe I can stop a
school shooting or I can stop a kid
that's being bullied that may be
suicidal and talking about it because
almost every child that we've seen that
has killed themselves have posted they
do post these like this is it I just
want to say goodbye to everybody or
whatever and you might be able to save a
child and they said they have saved
somebody from from from committing
suicide and you know I
doesn't bother me yeah they're not going
into private accounts and doing all that
stuff but they say they're not so okay
so they write they say they're looking
at the public stuff and I'm with you on
the sentiment of that that they're gonna
try to stop kids from killing themselves
or they can watch out for bullying or
that kind of stuff but isn't this really
just another layer of Big Brother
watching you and we're so were put now
it's becoming systemic to kids in middle
school so of course they're gonna grow
up and not care that the NSA is watching
them and all that keeps some use to the
nanny state right away the surveillance
state you're used to no matter what you
do the government knows somebody's
watching you and in its time right now
when we're cutting but local school
budgets and firing teachers what a
because there are better use of arts
resources than the hires of
[ __ ] that spy on kids Facebook
school has no art or music laugh I'd
rather spend forty thousand dollars
monitoring 13,000 students that way than
having ten teachers that have molested
children that are still on payroll
because
the damn unions we're talking about
budgets and schools and good teachers we
can go a long way the prices - if the
choices molesters or this program I'll
take this program but I don't think
that's isn't that necessary but let's
look at some numbers related to teens
and social media use ninety-one percent
of them post a photo of themselves
somewhere on social media 71% have their
school name this is probably on their
Facebook page 71% posts the city or town
where they live fifty-three percent have
their email address up there and 20
percent post their cell phone number I'm
99 percent sure that's all Facebook and
that's that was a Pew Center study so
already we're putting all this stuff out
there so that goes to the thing of why
do they have to hire a company to watch
it considering it's already all out
there you know they're just taking their
students and then probably you know they
probably have keywords or things that
stand out that they can quickly go
through a program and pick out potential
problems you know versus just trying to
click on 13,000 Facebook pages of their
students you know there's some risk
though in that kids just do and say
stupid stuff and when we did and said
stupid stuff in junior high and in high
school that if it was off school grounds
and you weren't punching a kid on school
you did it and then it worked itself out
but now if you're a kid and you post
something stupid or some joke that
doesn't quite make sense the school is
going to be all over you and you're
gonna get actually did happen there was
a girl who was she tweeted something
that the governor came to their high
school and she had tweeted something
about how you know he's a douchebag or
something and so the principal called
guys that girl got in trouble for
tweeting something about the governor
which i think is unbelievable this is
the trouble if the governor came to
school and she stood up and said you're
a douchebag to his face she probably
would do that though she'd be but she
did do it at public forum but you can't
write an article that's critical of the
of the governor of course you can this
is the interesting part this is the
interesting is it different if you were
well first off I think you're allowed I
mean legally you're allowed to call the
governor a douche bag if you want right
but there's you know you still make it
suspension or you might get you know
time after class or something for
disrespecting apology or somebody coming
your school I mean if you be disruptive
to class or whatever I mean you could
potentially still get in trouble right
the difference here is that in the old
days of man in the old days you might
have watched the governor speak and then
you walk out of there and you say to
your friends this guy's a douchebag
now you tweet it and now that's where
the danger lies now and I will just say
this is happening in Glendale so where
they're trying to monitor the social
media of the kids in Glendale and if you
notice school districts are doing it to
see it's not so because Glen day is full
of Armenians and they're very shifty so
that's maybe it's maybe not a bad idea
our girl Ana Kasparian is right that
she's one of the good she's part of that
5% you don't hear about exactly